- All right.
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to "Archives, Libraries
and Databases in Taiwan."
This is the second webinar
in our three-part series,
"Doing Chinese History (in a New Era)".
This series is organized by myself,
Denise Ho at Yale University,
and Emily Baum at UC Irvine.
And it has been generously sponsored
by the Council on East Asian
Studies at Yale University
and the Long US-China
Institute at UC Irvine.
We are also very grateful
to our co-sponsors
for helping to promote and
support these webinars.
They include Harvard
University's Fairbank Center,
the Center for East Asian
Studies at Stanford University,
the Project on China's Global Sharp Power
at the Hoover Institution,
the Center for Asian
Research at York University,
the Department of History
at Simon Fraser University,
the Institute of Asian Research
at the University of British Columbia,
the East Asian Studies Program
at Johns Hopkins University,
the East Asian Studies
program at UC Santa Cruz,
the Global China Center at
Hong Kong University of
Science and Technology,
and the Hong Kong Institute
for the Humanities and Social Sciences
at the University of Hong Kong.
Some of the presenters will
be speaking in Chinese,
but if you'd like to type
your question in English,
that's fine too.
In total, the webinars should last
for approximately 90 minutes
and it will be recorded in case
you can't stay until the end.
We'll send out the link
to the YouTube video
and a follow-up email to
all registered participants.
- So as most people are aware,
gaining access to
mainland Chinese archives
has gotten progressively more
difficult in recent years,
and COVID-19 has only
exacerbated the situation.
In last summer's edition
of this webinar series,
two of the three of our webinars
addressed the challenge of
accessing Chinese archives.
One of the webinars was on
introducing digital sources
for Chinese history,
and one was on introducing collections
beyond the traditional Chinese archive.
So they included collections
in the United States,
in Taiwan, in Japan
and on so-called garbology materials
or materials that are found
in unconventional places.
We will drop the links for
those videos in the chat.
So based on the responses
to last year's series,
we decided to dedicate a
full webinar this summer
to Taiwanese archives,
libraries and databases.
And in this session, we are very lucky
to be joined by four
archivists and historians
who will be introducing a
few noteworthy collections
from institutions
including Academia Sinica,
Academia Historica and the
National Archives Administration.
All of which hold copious materials,
not just on Taiwanese history,
but on mainland Chinese history as well.
So let us get started.
Today, we are going to be
joined by David Cheng Chang,
who is an associate professor of history
at Hong Kong University
of Science and Technology.
David is going to be guest
moderating this session.
David was really crucial
for helping to organize this webinar,
and we would very much like to thank him
as well as Quaklion Tang
at Harvard University
for helping to put us in touch
with our four presenters.
We are very grateful for their help.
So we will turn it over to David now
who is going to introduce our speakers
and he will also be responsible for
moderating this session
and handling the Q&A.
So David, why don't you take it away.
- Okay. Thank you Emily for
your generous introduction.
Thank you for attending this webinar.
The reason that I was invited
to guest moderate this event,
probably because Emily know
that when I was in grad school,
we were both at UC San Diego,
I only spent three days in PRC archives,
and I spent two years in Taiwan
doing archival research and oral history.
But of course I have to admit,
I did a lot of oral history research
in the mainland but only
three days in the archives.
So in Taiwan is really a treasure trove
for people doing research
on modern Chinese history.
Or today also Dr. Hsi-yuan Chen
is gonna speak about pre-modern materials,
so it's a great place to do research.
You should really start
your research in Taiwan,
no matter what project you're on.
Okay.
Now I'm gonna introduce four
distinguished panelists.
All four of them are historians
and two of them are archivists.
First that we're going
to have Dr. Hsi-yuan Chen
who is a research fellow
at the Institute of History and Phonology
and Academia Sinica.
He's also the director at the
Center for Digital Cultures,
and he received his PhD
from Harvard University
and his research interests are
archival research and the Qing history.
And next, we're gonna
have Dr. Hsiao Ya-hung
at the Institute of
Modern History Archives
at Academia Sinica and
he's a archivist there.
He received his PhD from
National Tsinghua University.
Formerly he worked at the
Academia Historica (speaks Chinese).
That's why we're gonna
ask him to also present
(speaks Chinese) holdings.
He also taught at
National Taipei University
of Nursing and Health Sciences
and National Defense Medical Center.
So his research interests
include modern China,
nursing in Taiwan, and archival studies.
Next Dr. Feng-yuan Hsu
at the National Archives Administration
of the National Development Council.
This organization's gonna become
the equivalent to US national archives.
That's my understanding and he's going to
explain exactly how this
archive actually is becoming,
which has become increasingly
important for any research.
He received his PhD from
National Chengchi University
and he is also an adjunct
assistant professor
at the Fu Jen Catholic University
and the Soochow University.
His research interests include
China's foreign relations,
Taiwan and international organizations,
disease prevention and treatment
and archival studies.
He has published numerous
articles and two books.
One of the books is
"WTO and Malaria Prevention
and Treatment in Taiwan".
Another book,
the "ROC Government in Nanjing
and the League of Nations"
and the finally we come
to our fourth speaker,
Dr. Shiuon Chu
at the Institute of the Modern History
of Academia Sinica
and he received his PhD
from Brown University.
Right now he's finishing
a book on the construction
of trust in examination in
China and Taiwan after the 1905
abolition of the imperial
exam system, keju.
After the presenters' presentations,
we're going to have about
roughly 20 minutes of Q&A,
but you can type your questions
in Q&A box at any time.
Probably you should type
your question along the way,
so I moderate the questions,
trying to get all questions answered.
You may choose to direct your
question to a specific speaker
or just a general question,
or if you need help with the translation,
either in Chinese or English,
you can type "Please translate".
I try my best to type
out just the translation,
but of course simultaneous translation
I type up in the Q&A box.
Thank you. Now let's move
on to Dr. Hsi-yuan Chen.
Dr. Chen, please.
- Hello everybody.
It's my pleasure to have
this opportunity to show you
the research and database
for technology in Taiwan
and thank you very much for the invitation
from the Yale MacMillan Center
Consult on East Asian Study.
Because the pandemic is
occurring all over the world,
and not only the state of
international politics,
but also the field academic research
has become more intense.
However, online database
is still a good method for researcher
to connect on knowledge and Taiwan.
Online database can let you
assess another new world.
So today's lecture,
we're focused on the
field of digital archives,
which we have developed in
the past 20 years in Taiwan.
As the current director for
Academia Sinica Center
for Digital Culture,
ASCDC, in this talk,
I will emphasize more work
produced by Academia Sinica
as well as share some of my
thought on historical research,
as my own research experiences.
Before I begin my talk,
I would like to me to ask the question.
Where are the boundary
of the technical skill,
to use by historian?
Especially in early 2020, John McNeill,
former person of American
Historical Association,
said that in terms of historic research,
the golden age of tradition documents
is already passed its peak.
The new age of historical research,
introduce a diversified historical source
and a research method.
This maybe a time to build our new skills,
so I hope my lecture can give everyone
some assistance on this point.
The first one I want to share with you
is about a timeline of
Taiwan digital archive.
The Chinese computerization
lags the west by 30 years,
but there's two critical
automation projects in Taiwan.
Taiwan was the first in the world
to begin Chinese text
digitalization project.
Under that you can see the photo
of Academia Sinica in the General Assembly
in 1984,
when they first decided to create
a center for computation technology.
The first material to be digitalized
were treaties and food
and commodities too.
A database of historical
(speaks Chinese) corporate.
And finishing his
historical database project
at the Institute of History and Philology.
Launching a construction of
the other full text database
for Confucian texts of history, philosophy
and literature texts and so on.
So Taiwan become the leader
in the so-called Chinese book
database in the early 1990s.
More over, the database
method of searching
and using traditional archive
caused a revolution in
the field of literature
and history research in Taiwan,
and even impacting research
all over the world.
So this image is from the
2020s Wonderwall Center
for each of the cultures who
collaborated the project,
developing word segmentation
and the part of the speech
taking for Chinese copers.
This is only the pivoting
from text to object.
Beside the digital texts
that became digitalizing,
biological specimen record,
maps, archeology, and anthropology code,
artifacts and image, et cetera.
In terms of technology,
we also began to focus on
digitalization standards,
metadata specification
and 3D monitoring and database management.
This type of high integrated,
national level digital archive project
was (speaks Chinese) unrivaled
in the world at the time.
So you can see our logo of
the past project on the left.
Looking back on this period of history,
we can see that although
Taiwan arrived late
to the digital trend of the modern world.
It nevertheless quickly rose to become
one of the pioneers of digital humanity.
On the left, a list
just some of the current, long
time collaboration of ASCDC
and we are always
beginning new partnerships.
So this slide summarize the timeline
I just have described so far.
You can see that different goals
were pursued during
different time periods.
To today, I have
helped a digital archive
walk of my predecessors,
and continue to find ways
to seek a new breakthroughs.
We will take a look at the
current project of ASCDC.
So first is the so-called
building a knowledge base
and to do the tool research,
development and maintenance.
We also encourage a scholar
from Academia Sinica
to use digital humanities
tools and knowledge bases
to carry out their research study.
We also produce both physical
and virtual publication
and making humanity research accessible
through a variety of channels.
ASCDC has many excellent technical staff
who research and develop tools
to enable humanity research
to conduct research in a
new and efficient ways.
This research could face some big samples.
Family's introduction to a
digital humanity research tool,
developed by Academia Sinica
Center for Digital Cultures.
There are two (indistinct) tests,
an uncensored research platform,
an image analysis test platforms.
I want to highlight that this platform,
this text analysis platform,
also kind of English interface.
This an example of how you can use
a digital humanity research platform.
You can search a text or a novel,
for example the "Dream
of the Red Chambers",
for change in the frequency of the word
is praising emotional content.
The so-called image analysis
system we developed,
with a double or triple I and F standards
to cross platform compatibility,
as well as function for image comparison,
content regulation, et cetera.
The open museum we
developed in recent years
is a kind of vital space that integrated
collection, display and
application functions.
The preference showcase at
Academia Sinica's research
and the trends into a wider audience.
(mouse clicking quietly)
- My colleague, professor Cust,
he gathered 20 Academia Sinica
humanity and social
science scholars on board.
Project funded by the rapid response
to (indistinct) on COVID-19
and the social sciences.
Within the few months,
the team composed popularly
assessed both sides' articles.
Following the Academia Sinica's
launch of the reflection
on COVID-19 website this year.
Companion books published the worst
and they're printed on just
five days ago on July 15th.
This book features 90 articles
by 20 humanities and
social science scholars
whose work contributed
a veritable knowledge
to Taiwanese society during
this critical period.
Now we introduce
four of Taiwan's most
important archive institutes,
as well as their most notable database.
You can see
some important digital
archive institute in Taiwan
on the screen,
like Academia Sinica,
National Taiwan University,
and National Palace Museum
and National Central Library.
If you look at the four,
you are looking for classical
Chinese texts again.
The hanji and the Scripta Sinica database
is an excellent resources.
It was built by IHP to cover
a wide variety of collections.
Over the past 30 years,
you have collected Chinese
literature from different eras,
including the rare books that mention
historic material, treaty and chart.
We also have the known, the so-called
veritable record of the Ming
dynasty and the Qing dynasty
and the Korean Joseon dynasty.
For example if you look for the
information regarding eunuchs,
you can see from the (speaks Chinese),
that the Ming dynasty
requested a eunuch from Korea.
From the Joseon dynasty record,
you can also find a historical
record of the Joseon dynasty
distributing a eunuch to the Ming dynasty.
Of course the narrative, the narration
would be different and
worst in comparison.
Academia Sinica's book collection
would put a great effort to
ensure the accuracy of the text.
So we can see on the detail level,
revisions highlighted in the red scripta,
Sinica includes access to
the major Buddhist work,
"Taisho Tripitaka",
which I use here as an example.
Now I will use an example
from the region that
everyone may be familiar with,
the Chinese to Wuhan.
This is a historic building
here known as their
Yellow Crane Tower
(speaks Chinese).
- Which is one of my research topics.
The Scripta Sinica database connects
highly accurate texts on
the traditional catalog
of the (speaks Chinese),
including Taoist and
the Buddhist literature.
We can find a painting
and many other results in a database,
if you do a keyword search
for "Yellow Crane Tower".
We can look for what field
we want to see through.
For example, here
I can use the text (speaks Chinese)
and notation (speaks Chinese),
including a turn to the correct
spelling (speaks Chinese).
We can see the results showing
(speaks Chinese) title, et cetera.
We can also search the catalog directly
by any keywords of which is highlight,
who has appeared on the test in the text.
We can select different texts
or give an addition of the
syntax and compare them
using text comparison function.
We can even bring up the
digitalized image of the original text
to see how an original first appeared.
Then you can filter your
research results even more
by searching for multiple keywords.
So like here, we just
use some single words,
like use the (speaks Chinese)
and the fruit and the (speaks Chinese).
We can provide a kind of
text comparison function.
We can use the single word search
and we can use the three
keywords at the same time.
We can provide with a
compare to compare function.
(speaks Chinese) ISP
Scripta Sinica databases
are integrated with the
search analysis platform.
We can directly search for,
organize a list of names,
so people, place, the
no feature positions.
There is a (speaks Chinese).
Here I'll give you an example,
a (speaks Chinese).
The document of the IHP Scripta Sinica
can link and hyperlink to the database
for official names,
which is built in collaboration with
the National Palace Museum Taipei.
So database of (speaks Chinese)
so you can see here.
In Taiwan the major
database (speaks Chinese)
and archive of ancient literature
are shown on this slide.
So they are including Scripta Sinica,
IHP Digital Archives Online,
and National Palace Museum
Database of Rare Books
and National Central Library
Rare Books and Special
Collections database.
I won't go into any detail.
You can take a look at that.
And also you can compare with the
various kind of Chinese book database,
which I believe everybody
here are familiar with.
(speaks Chinese) Scripta
Sinica (speaks Chinese).
We could also have some
important collections
such as Ming-Qing archives
which were transported from China.
In the fall of 1948 and the tide
of the Chinese civil world was turned.
(speaks Chinese) recommended
that the archeology relics
of the Institution of
History and Philology,
Academia Sinica be relocated to Taiwan.
So the (speaks Chinese) and
the (speaks Chinese) archives
was transported in a long route
through Beijing (speaks Chinese)
and finally ending in Taiwan.
The archive of the Grand
Secretariat (speaks Chinese),
put together by the Institution
of History and Philology,
and they collect a boundary note
310,000 items including a period decree,
imperial (speaks Chinese),
memorial tribute (speaks
Chinese) and et cetera.
So how important are the
Grand Secretariat Archives?
I will call a description
from the well-known historian Fu Ssu-nien.
He said, "The archive's treasures
include private written accounts.
The limited knowledge from
official documents alone
are unreliable to unveil
the reality of dynasty."
All the political truths could
be unearthed in this archive.
This is the database we've
been working in since 2001.
So in the past century,
there has been, for example,
in the past century,
there's been a controversy
concerning the ascension
of (speaks Chinese) emperor to the throne.
One of the key pieces of evidence
is the Kangxi emperor's last testament,
which is stored in the (speaks Chinese).
This list of evidence has drawn
much attention for us to
discover in this field.
So (speaks Chinese) the last testament,
you can find the emperor
Kangxi's last testament.
So this is the Kangxi
emperor's last testament,
which clearly indicates
the fourth prince of (speaks
Chinese) was his chosen one.
(mouse clicks)
- We are also kind of a
collection of rubbings
at the Institute of History and Philology.
We have a large number of rubbings,
a variety of dynasties and
generation are collected,
including rubbings over oracle bones,
inscription bronze whale rubbings,
Han dynasty stone relief rubbings,
Buddhist stone sculpture rubbings,
and Liao-Jin-Yuan dynasty stone rubbings.
These precious rubbings
can be used to compare
the literature passed
down through generations
to better understand the
ancient Chinese history
and the culture regarding divination,
sacrifice and mythology,
religion, so on and so forth.
This is a list of the rubbing
collection in Academia Sinica.
Of course the modern
Chinese history database.
They also integrate them together
several Academia Sinicas
and the smaller, modern
historical database,
and offer a convenient
English to interface.
My colleague Dr. Hsiao Ya-Hung,
well I believe he will
give you details later.
Here I just use an
example from my research.
(speaks Chinese) He
researched a (speaks Chinese).
You can find a result (speaks Chinese).
You now, (speaks Chinese)
handicraft produced
in the imperial record
of the Qing dynasty.
If you search for (speaks Chinese),
you can see on the screen
that the general (speaks Chinese)
left behind many records
to (speaks Chinese)
during the war time.
(speaks Chinese) was a representative
of the Republic of China in 1945,
at the signing of the instrument
of the surrender of Japan that ended WWII.
He also the minister of a border
military operation in 1949.
Aside and outside the Academia Sinica,
I want to introduce the
kind of (speaks Chinese).
Briefly give you an
idea of (speaks Chinese)
which (speaks Chinese) University.
From the document, you
can see the relationship
between China and Taiwan
during the Qing rule,
which is presented as central
versus local government relationship,
as well as structurally
as a center versus a
peripheral relationship.
We can not only see the archive
to learn early Taiwanese legal history,
local administrative history
and socioeconomic history,
but also to know the relation between the
administrative area of Taiwan and China.
Picture here is the archive
record about a gambling fraud.
Above all the learning about Taiwan
is done not only to
know the area of Taiwan,
but also a vital introduction
into the history of China.
We can see an interrelation between
Taiwan and central government of the time.
So as updated in the map,
murders such as this.
Now, we could also find even
the data (speaks Chinese)
about the murder site
as shown on this map.
We do have the speaker here to speak about
the collection in the
National Palace Museum,
so I just give a brief idea
about the Qing archive,
stored in the National Palace Museum
because the National Palace
Museum Database of Rare Books
has recently updated its interface
to make it easier to research.
(speaks Chinese) registering
an account is required
to view image at high resolution.
To preview image are
actually quite all ready,
so data field and the keywords
provide also quite comprehensive.
We can again, search the
keyword (speaks Chinese),
Yellow Crane Tower, here.
Information from the image,
the poetry and the tribal notes
can be found throughout the database.
As for the National Central
Library Special Collection,
the platform requires a specific
name or book or author
or ISBN for research.
However you can still view
a few digitalized images
from ancient books.
Take the Yellow Crane Tower for example.
Again,
if you can find a name of a related point
or texts from on the database,
you can use the information to search
the National Central
Library Special Collection
website with a copy of the full image.
Let me give you a show
of concluding remarks.
Why I'm studying the various
kind of online open resource
in Taiwan that research can still access
this in a difficult
situation under COVID-19.
As a humanities scholar,
I cannot help but get
everyone to interest.
So in this, the world of digital humanity,
how should a scholar define themself?
During the past,
the well known historian
Fu Ssu-nien wrote,
"In his (speaks Chinese)".
He said that, "We are not reader of books.
(speaks Chinese) So we
are simply searching
the heaven above and the underworld below,
moving off hands and
feet to seek things out."
In the area of digitalization,
scholars don't necessarily have to travel
up and down the world,
to collect firsthand material
or archeological finding.
Now with the vast amount of
digital archive and databases,
as well as the meditation
by digital tools,
these things (speaks
Chinese) generating their own
hands and feet
through AI, through algorithms, et cetera.
That required us to put
together their connection
in a structured and contextualized way.
Furthermore different
researchers and institutes
must become able to exchange their data
and the document digitally.
You work on to compliment each
artist works and findings.
However, with a terribly
convenient database,
you may wonder in this new era,
do we still need historian?
Or do we only construct, deconstruct
or manipulate big data
masquerading as knowledge
in this digital world?
This is in my humble opinion that
in upcoming brave new digital world,
there's still a lot of unknown
territory for us to explore.
Thank you for listening. Thanks.
(mouse clicks)
- Thank you, Dr. Chen for this
extremely rich, informative presentation.
Good news, everyone!
If you miss a lot of details,
since he had to go very quickly,
I will send out, email you the
PowerPoint he just presented,
so you can see all the
links and all the detail.
Okay, great.
Now we're going to move
on to our next speaker,
Dr. Hsiao Ya-Hung of Academia Sinica's
Modern Institute Archives.
Ya-Hung, please.
- In February 1955,
Academia Sinica established
a preparatory committee
for the Institution of Modern History
and they invited parishioner
(speaks Chinese),
a renowned historian
to serve as its chair.
The new work of the community included
requirement of a research personnel,
formulation of a research plan,
pursuit of Chinese and Western books
and the connection of historian materials
from both official and private sources.
(speaks Chinese)
- [David] (speaks Chinese)
- (speaks Chinese)
- (speaks Chinese) John King Fairbank
visited Institution of Modern History
Academia Sinica in 1964.
Last title is "Fairbank".
The archives were established in 1958,
three years after the Institution
of Modern History was
formally established.
In 1988, a building was found.
A building to house the materials
the institution had in collection.
After more than half a century
of meticulous collection,
the content important
original historian cost
and the service a major
response for reform
research on modern Chinese history.
The diplomatic files are the
highlight of these archives,
which content continue from office records
from the late Qing dynasty,
(speaks Chinese) Republic
of China in Taiwan,
that including files of the office
in charge of foreign affairs,
Zongli yaman,
the Ministry of External Affairs,
and the Ministry of Foreign Affairs
of the Northern Government
of the Republic of China in Taiwan.
Most governmental files are
worth special attention.
During the years 1912 to 1938,
they are divided into 48 categories.
According to subject matters,
important events from
around the time China
first entered the republic (indistinct).
During the European War,
senior Russian relations
and a special meeting on
(indistinct) including.
Economic files.
The economic files constitute
the largest single stack
of materials of these archives,
including the records of
the Committee Ministry,
and the Ministry of
Agriculture and Commerce,
the Ministry of Industry,
the Ministry of Economic Affairs
and the document of Foreign
World Economic of Trade
after the national
government retreat to Taiwan.
(microphone static thumping)
(mouse clicks)
They are important primary
source materials on the
economic development of
Republic of China and Taiwan.
For example, economic files,
Resource Committee Archives.
"The archives are
important modern technology
and industrial history materials."
"The Resource Committee Archives
are stored in three locations,
the Archives of Institute
of Modern History,
Academia Sinica,
Academia Historica,
and the Second Historical
Archives in Nanjing, China."
"Personal Papers: Dr. Chu Chia-hua".
"Over the past 10 years,
the focus of our collection
has gradually shifted from
official documents to private papers."
Other than personnel documents
of those who (indistinct)
had important military
and political relation
and the lighting program in
Phoenix and the medicine.
We also collect (indistinct)
of five institutions,
(indistinct) and the
group and any materials
that can contribute to the
study of modern history.
Those papers not only
deepen our understanding
of the Republic idea,
but also show light on the early
history of Academia Sinica.
(speaks Chinese)
Personal papers.
We have Dr. Robert Lim.
Lim was a (speaks Chinese).
Lim was an esteemed physiologist who
contributed greatly to teaching
and research on physiology
and played a key role in the development
of the military medicine system
during the Sino-Japanese War.
Lim's papers including letters,
works and reference
notes from pain research.
Now we have also Kwoh-ting Li
or K.T. Li (speaks Chinese).
Li's paper was about
economical polarization
is possible in Taiwan.
(shuffling)
- Huai River Control Commission Project.
The Huai Commission not
only use modern technology
in water conversation project
but trained skillful
technicians and engineers
who worked with the national government
first to the southwest
during the Sino-Japanese War.
(page turns)
- The picture is the Huai River
Control Commission Project.
The Huai River Water Control Commission
purchased machine materials
for hydraulic drilling project
in the 19 (speaks Chinese).
(silence)
The Ministry of Agriculture
and Forestry Project.
"Based on the files of the
Agricultural Promotion Commission
housed at the Archives,
this project examines how modern China
tried to promote agriculture during
and after the second World War."
"It will also add 1,000
more agriculture experts
to the existing social network system
and increase its number
to 2,000 in total."
(silence)
- We use a database, Military
News Agency Database.
The Military News Agency is a
(indistinct) of the
Ministry of National Defense
is a military background
give the other (indistinct)
in produce a hand live
news and valuable photos,
especially from the
1915 through the 1970s,
when Taiwan was still under military law.
"By digitizing all the
news and the pictures,
this Archives provides a valuable platform
for studying military history and the
international relations
during the Cold War."
(silence)
We have many maps.
The map of China provides
"maps of waterways
and maps of the world among others."
(silence)
Yeah.
The archives website and email.
We visit the reading room
hours Monday to Friday.
The collection online is free.
(silence)
The other archival repository
in Taipei: Academia Historica.
(speaks Chinese)
The National Government Archives
important political and military
(speaks Chinese)
(speaks Chinese) National
Government Archives
(speaks Chinese)
personal information banker
(silence)
(speaks Chinese)
Taiwan (speaks Chinese)
Archives (speaks Chinese)
(speaks Chinese)
Thank you for your
attention. (speaks Chinese)
- Thank you, Ya-Hung.
That's such a rich presentation.
Naturally from his presentation we can see
a lot of books actually came
out from these archives,
especially the recent new book
by (speaks Chinese), right?
And also (speaks Chinese)
and also earlier book
by (speaks Chinese).
Also, my own book benefit
from this archive.
(speaks Chinese)
Thank you. Now let's move
on to Dr. Feng-yuan Hsu
of the National Archive Administration.
(speaks Chinese) Feng-yuan
(speaks Chinese).
Yep. (speaks Chinese)
- [Feng-Yuan] (speaks Chinese)
- (speaks Chinese)
- (speaks Chinese) (laughs) Okay.
- [Feng-Yuan] (laughing) (speaks Chinese)
(clicking)
(shuffling)
- Hey! Good evening, everyone.
My English is so poor,
so I only can you use
Chinese to say something.
(mouse clicks)
(sliding)
- (speaks Chinese)
COVID-19 (speaks Chinese)
(speaks Chinese)
Taiwan (speaks Chinese)
So easy (speaks Chinese)
(speaks Chinese)
Taiwan (speaks Chinese)
your email (speaks Chinese)
(speaks Chinese)
email (speaks Chinese)
Taiwan (speaks Chinese)
(speaks Chinese)
email (speaks Chinese)
- (speaks Chinese)
Yeah, this is so rich.
It's so overwhelming. I
think people just say,
"Oh, how can I keep up with this?"
No worry.
We're gonna send this PowerPoint to you.
You're gonna follow all
the links. Follow them.
Follow the National
Archive Administration,
the future National
(speaks Chinese) of Taiwan.
Okay, now let's move on to Shiuon Chu.
Dr. Chu.
- Thank you, David for the introduction.
I would like to also
thank Denise and Emily
for putting the panel together.
I also thank (speaks Chinese)
for putting me in touch with this
very dynamic group.
I appreciate this chance
to share my thoughts
about doing Chinese history
with materials in Taiwan,
and also doing "Chinese
History in Taiwan" as well.
And as we have three very
informative presentations ahead,
so I have the luxury to present
in a less informative way
or somewhat random way.
Okay.
I was born and raised in Hong Kong.
So Taiwan or the Republic of China
has never been unfamiliar for me,
nor do I see the Republic of China
as something in past tense.
So the Republic is still ongoing,
but back then I did not know
how relevant this could be
to my own research and career.
I did my masters degree on late
imperial history in Taiwan,
on (speaks Chinese) history.
I was attracted by the works
of the very strong cohort
of late Imperial scholar (speaks Chinese).
Here or actual (speaks
Chinese) is definitely
one of the towering figures in this field.
Only after I started my PhD in the States,
I started to think seriously
about the history of
the Republic of China
in Taiwan after 1949.
As well I entered the modern China field
and worked with Rebecca
Nedostup, my advisor,
and she had already started
her fascinating project
on displacement of both living
people and also dead bodies
in mid-20th century China and Taiwan.
We read documents together and
I benefited a lot from her.
Over the course of my PhD research,
I did archival and
library research in China,
mostly the (speaks Chinese)
Second Historical Archive,
library research in the US.
I rely heavily on oral directs,
so I can stay in Prague
and then just go to Walcats
and then order the books and
took the send to our library,
which is not particularly,
they don't have a very rich
collection of east Asian books,
and also alas Taiwan.
But when I started
writing my dissertation,
I found that the materials
in Taiwan did not just
support existing research agendas.
They do not support
existing research questions.
These materials in Taiwan also changed
how I formulate my research questions,
how I defined a scope of research,
and actually quite
fundamentally has changed
how I prioritize the 20th century
Chinese and Taiwanese history.
So move on.
The question I came across
was how to make sense
of the Republic of China beyond 1949.
Who think the Republic of China after '49,
the equation can change a lot.
The question we asked for now
will be confined to something like
the cause of the 1949 tobacco,
or how the wars supported the development
during the Nanjing decade.
We can now ask questions like,
how did the ROC, the Republic of China,
government and with the legal,
which that function though with
a lot of flaws and problems
for at least another
three decades in Taiwan,
despite the wars.
The wars in fact,
helped to build and
consolidate the system.
So we can ask very
different kinds of questions
and we had to have very different kinds
of prioritization scheme.
Sometimes I would call this
"The Long Republican Period".
At last, at the end,
I wrote an dissertation that
spanned from 1905 to 1980s.
Nearly one-third of this
is about post 1949 Taiwan.
From then on,
I did not just do Chinese
history in Taiwan,
(speaks Chinese) presence in Taiwan,
but I also do Chinese history in Taiwan,
the Chinese history of the
Republic of China in Taiwan.
That's why I choose this as the
title of my presentation today.
For archival research, we
have Feng-yuan and Ya-Hung,
who have already done
a lot of heavy lifting,
so I should focus on some
database and publish materials.
But unfortunately, and
then I also see this,
from some of the questions
raised in the chatroom,
about where to find a hop
or where to find a go-to
website or go-to site,
to look at all these materials,
at least get a sense of
where these materials are.
Unfortunately, the
post-'49 book collections
were actually quite scattered.
They rarely formed their
own special collections.
In the following presentation,
I would look at three categories,
instead of using libraries as units.
(speaks Chinese) of materials.
I think that they give
a sense that how and why
studying the Republic of
China after '49 in Taiwan
is an intellectually promising field
or intellectually promising project.
The first kind of materials is related to
(speaks Chinese) materials
and then related to the
Chinese Constitution in Taiwan.
As you may already know that
the constitution of the
Republic of China is drafted
in Nanjing and then eventually migrated
with the Nationalist
Government to Taiwan after '49.
This is a very interesting
constitution in many ways.
It contained a very
peculiar five-power system
designed by Sun Yat-sen.
Under this system,
there are two different powers outside
of the traditional free power system.
We have the examination
power and control power.
The control power which modeled
after the (speaks Chinese),
the census system from Imperial China.
There are quite lots of problems
and difficulties created
by this constitution.
Not only because this is
a Chinese constitution,
made in China and then taken to Taiwan,
but because of the disparate
Curio five-power constitution.
To deal with these problems,
we have a long list of "Interpretations
by Justices of the Judicial Yuan",
the judicial branch of the
Republic of China's government.
There's a database.
It may be something
quite big in this level,
but I still find it very
intellectually stimulating
to look at just these interpretations.
It covers not only those
constitutional level kind of problems,
like territory or like the definition of
who is or who is not civil servants,
because that's quite problematic things
under the system of examination power.
You can also see a lot of very interesting
and everyday life things
in these interpretations,
including the regulations over adoption
of children in the civic law
and then the licensing
of medical practitioners,
so and so forth.
There's quite a lot of
different things in these interpretations.
These are all openly accessible online
and then you can see the hyperlink here
and also draw attention to another system,
which is also from the judicial yuan,
the judicial branch of the ROC
government and that is called
"Judicial Yuan Law and
Regulations Retrieving System".
That's quite a wealth
of materials in this.
They have cases and their
completely searchable,
although sometimes after they
have updated their system,
unfortunately the search
engine become less sensitive
and I use it two or three years ago.
Still there's quite a
lot that can be found
in these two sites, these two databases.
Then this brings our
attention to the specific
or particular legal issues
emerged after '49 in Taiwan
because of the Republic of China system.
I would just walk you
through the (speaks Chinese),
the justice interpretations.
From 1949 to present,
there are in total 805 interpretations.
You can access them in full text
from this website, through this website.
They also have an English version,
but if I remember correctly,
they have translation of 600ish
of these interpretations.
So I think that's this.
That's a lot of quite
interesting materials
in these interpretations.
Then for me,
if you want to look for some topics,
that are partly related
to China and Taiwan,
over the 20th century.
Typically this can be quite rewarding
to take a look at these interpretations,
and also the judicial
experience website as well.
Okay.
I will move on to
another kind of materials
or another (speaks Chinese) of materials.
The (speaks Chinese),
which is "Publications of
Native Place Associations".
Native Place Associations
have been a phenomenon
in late imperial modern Chinese history.
The publication of
Native Place Associations
actually proliferated after '49
and in the format of magazine
and they usually use
a title like something
a political province and
then (speaks Chinese).
In this example (speaks Chinese).
These materials,
actually these (speaks Chinese)
is actually some kind of institutions
that shape and also reproduce identities,
Chinese identities after '49,
quite important in this sense.
Where to find these kinds of materials?
I'll draw attention to
the (speaks Chinese),
the National Central Library.
(speaks Chinese)
which is the database
of Taiwan periodicals.
Back in the days,
I love the function of "browse by issue"
of this (speaks Chinese).
But sadly their recent renovation
or their recent updates of their system,
they canceled this function,
so you cannot just press
the particular issue
of a particular periodical and
then find the titles of the,
at least you could have a look
at the titles of the articles,
but you cannot do it anymore,
but still (speaks Chinese).
If you know what to look for
and if you know something
about the keywords,
about the titles of
the kind of periodicals
you want to look for,
still is the go-to database,
still is the database to go to first
before you do further research.
Then I also know that there's
a recent (speaks Chinese)
constructed by mainland China company.
This is called Taiwan (speaks Chinese).
It requires subscription,
but you can partially access
to the table of contents
of these magazines through this database.
I watched one of the YouTube
videos of the last series
and then I think it's
terribly (indistinct).
He walked us through the
(speaks Chinese) website,
about how to use auction websites
to conduct preliminary
research with materials,
especially post-'49 materials.
I also think that this also works well
with Taiwanese materials after '49.
So auctions websites in Taiwan,
you have (speaks Chinese).
You also have (speaks Chinese).
Those are auction websites.
Actually, you can find quite
a lot of good stuff there.
Then I'll also walk you through
one of the issues of
this (speaks Chinese),
give you a sense of what it
looked like in these kind
of magazines published by
Native Place Associations.
As you can see,
it's not always
informative for historians,
so it provides a lots of anecdotes
and lots of personal recollections.
They may not be firsthand
experience versus materials,
but sometimes they provide lots of
unexpected help for researchers.
I personally find a
biography is most helpful
in this category, in this genre,
of Native Place Association magazines.
You can see at the bottom,
you have (speaks Chinese),
a biography of (speaks Chinese).
(speaks Chinese) is not
a very famous scholar,
but actually he play for important part
in the introduction of IQ
tests and standardized tests
into China and Taiwan,
and then his career span
from mainland to Taiwan.
He is quite a, for my own research,
he is quite important.
He's a quite an obscure
person, so you cannot find it.
It's difficult to find his biography
or biographical information,
but this issue of the
(speaks Chinese) say to be.
Sometimes you can see biographies.
A lot of very interesting
and important people
from this Native Place magazines.
Then that's gonna be extremely
useful for researchers.
Then for more than,
I'm not sure if that's true,
for other modern Chinese scholars,
but for me who work from
late imperial period to modern period,
I find that sometimes
it's difficult to find
a stable pool of biographies
for figures, for individuals,
in the modern period.
In the (speaks Chinese) period,
those go to (indistinct).
We have dictionary of
(indistinct) biography.
For the (speaks Chinese),
we have the (speaks Chinese).
We have the (speaks Chinese).
Those kind of regular (speaks
Chinese) book to go to,
or later the (speaks Chinese).
Or later we have the (speaks Chinese)
constructed by the (speaks Chinese).
For more than history,
historians sometimes it's
difficult to locate someone,
especially some upscale person's
biographical information.
I think that the Native
Place Association magazine,
maybe it can provide some
help in this (speaks Chinese).
Okay.
Then I move on to the
third kind of materials.
I find it very interesting
and then tells us a lot of
the intellectual promise
about doing Chinese history
after '49 in Taiwan.
It's called (speaks Chinese)
or literally translated at
"research on communist bandits".
For obvious reasons,
this is also a (speaks Chinese),
which proliferated after '49.
Unfortunately again,
these kind of materials
or these kind of books,
we do not have very focused,
specialized collection of this,
but the good thing is that
in the Kuo Ting-Yi Library
of my home institution,
IMHAS Institute of Modern History.
We have a 000 section in this library.
That's actually, that's a
small room on the first floor
of the Kuo Ting-Yi Library.
You can see nearly all
these (speaks Chinese)
read the books stored in that room.
That's quite helpful if someone
have the chance to visit
Kuo Ting-Yi library.
It can be quite rewarding just
to browse through the stack.
Sometimes it's provides
a lot of inspiration,
just to browse through the stacks,
instead of directly using the database.
Another place for this kind of,
like another hub for this
kind of (speaks Chinese) materials,
I think this should be
the Libraries of National
Cheng Chi University.
(speaks Chinese) has
been one of the center
for (speaks Chinese) for a very long time.
They have a lot of
these kind of materials,
but unfortunately,
those materials are stored
in different libraries,
different (speaks Chinese),
so you have to have a sense of
what to look for before going there.
These are the two places I can think about
if you want to situate
or want to locate (speaks
Chinese) materials.
Again, I recommend going
to auction websites
and then to do preliminary research,
like going to the (speaks
Chinese) to look for materials,
post-'49 materials,
or at least have a sense
of what it looked like
before further research,
because there's quite a
lot of things put online
and to be sold these days.
And then the sellers
often provide pictures,
a table of contents,
that can be helpful by itself,
no matter if you purchase it or not.
I also recommend going
to auction websites.
Then if you want to look for
these kind of (speaks Chinese) materials.
Once again, these (speaks
Chinese) materials
are not something that can be
used as firsthand materials,
especially on PRC history.
But for me,
it's extremely useful to reconstruct
the information circuits
between ROC, Republic of China,
and PRC (speaks Chinese)
or politically confronting regimes.
They're supposed to be detached
from each other during the Cold War.
If you look closer at this
(speaks Chinese) materials,
you can still see there's
a information circuits
working over the Cold War.
This is something I'm very interested in.
Then in one of my recent side projects,
I look at the simplification
character project in Taiwan.
Usually we think that Taiwan
use traditional Chinese characters,
and then the PRC they
simplified characters.
Actually there's lots of
ongoing efforts to simplify
or to introduce simplified
characters in Taiwan,
over the 50s, 60s and 70s
during the so-called authoritarian rule.
That's quite strange.
Then actually there's
a lot of common ground
between the intellectuals in Taiwan
and then in mainland China,
in terms of simplified characters.
This is something I read
from Wang Shijie diary.
Then he wrote this (speaks Chinese) book
and then he didn't just
write it as a condemnation
of the way the communist bandits
destroyed Chinese culture in China,
but actually he took it very seriously.
It took those information
in these books seriously
as possible projects
or alternative projects
to simplify Chinese characters.
Then these projects can
give resource to him to
think about the way characters
can be simplified in Taiwan.
That's something quite counterintuitive.
They are not confronting
with Wang Shijie accurately,
borrow intellectual
resources from each other.
Wang Shijie has a long
history as a (speaks Chinese),
has a long history of
doing simplifications,
since the days in (speaks Chinese).
He has ongoing interest for
the simplification of Chinese characters,
even after moving to Taiwan after '49.
That's something I find quite interesting
and that's something I also find useful
in this kind of (speaks
Chinese) materials.
Okay. Time is running short,
so I'll end my presentation
with a piece of material
that I find interesting recently.
This material itself tells a story about
how books, not just people, migrates
but also how books and then migrates
and how books, how to reproduction
and then how do the reproduction of books
can tell stories about
the Republic of China
in Taiwan after '49.
Okay.
The book I'm dealing with this
is called (speaks Chinese),
"A Historical Analysis
of the Chinese Society"
by (speaks Chinese).
(speaks Chinese) is a
very famous politician
and also scholar,
is the founder of the (speaks Chinese)
School of Social History
and Economic History.
He has a lot of influence
in post-war Taiwan,
both pre-'49 and mainland
Chinese historography.
He is also a strong influence over
people, scholars, historians
in the academic in Taiwan after '49.
This is one of his
- [David] Shiuon, Shiuon
Shiuon, you have one minute.
- Okay, yeah.
- [David] One minute left.
- Oh, I have one minute left?
Oh okay, so I'll just wrap up.
Okay, so this is a book written by him.
We have the Taipei edition,
and then we also have the Beijing edition.
You have to just look
at the Beijing addition.
You miss a lot of things here,
which is first this is a book.
When (speaks Chinese) went
to republish this book,
he didn't have a copy with him in the 50s.
He borrowed one from the
(speaks Chinese) collection
and then the (speaks
Chinese) collection actually
got from the Taihoku Imperial
University collection.
This collection was acquired.
This book was acquired
maybe in the 20s or 30s
by the (speaks Chinese)
imperial universities.
That's quite interesting.
The author himself lost the older copy,
but he retrieved this copy from
so-called enemies collection.
Then actually this collection,
I think the most
important takeaway is that
this book, this copy,
is completely accessible
through the Taiwan E-Book database.
You can see on the top right corner,
you will see the seal of the Taipei
Taihoku Imperial University.
That's quite interesting for me because
usually you assume you have to
go into a special collection
to look for this (speaks Chinese)
of (speaks Chinese) of editions.
Sometimes if you browse
through this database.
I think that the (speaks
Chinese) book database
is quite a generous database.
It provides a lot of very
useful and very valuable books
and then with high resolution,
uploaded completely online.
This is one of the examples.
This book also tells a lot of stories,
but I do not have time to.
The republication of this book actually,
I think it's quite interesting,
but I don't have time to move on.
Just give me one more minute
for the final, final, final wrap up.
The point I want to make
with these materials
and this (speaks Chinese) book is that
so the texts, the books,
the materials in Taiwan,
they not just perfect alternatives,
choices of materials
to do Chinese history,
but also they significantly changed
the way we frame our questions
about Chinese history
and then change the way we prioritize,
change the scope of doing Chinese history.
I think that it will be very rewarding
to look into the stories of these books,
why and how they
eventually exist in Taiwan.
Then they can be very
intentionally rewarding.
That's my most general, general points
I want to make with this presentation.
Thank you for attention.
- Great. Thank you, Dr. Chu
for your thoughtful reflection.
Now we have, we're a little over time so
we're just over, now 9:05.
We have five minutes left for Q&A,
but I'm gonna do it very quickly.
Some of the questions have been answered
in the Q&A box.
You can look at them
and the remaining questions I think,
they're around a few themes.
Number one,
I think Shiuon also mentioned this.
Madeline (speaks Chinese)
asked this question,
is there a central platform
or convenient clearing house
with links to all archives?
That also shows which ones
we can access online?"
(speaks Chinese)
Go with panelists,
you can turn on your video and your audio.
(speaks Chinese)
- [Ya-Hung] (speaks Chinese)
- (speaks Chinese)
- [Ya-Hung] Okay.
- Yeah, not exactly.
That's a very similar question
to Spencer's question,
which I answered.
Is there kind of reference
site or indexing websites
for compiling all the digital database.
As a matter of fact, the
(speaks Chinese) of Taiwan
(speaks Chinese), T-I-R-E-U-C,
which I put in my answer to
Lu Spencer's question.
- Oh yeah.
- It is a kind of portal to
(speaks Chinese) database.
It is Data Digital Taiwan.
So you can use the digital one,
it's kind of (speaks Chinese).
It's kind of a search for
showcase built by my center.
It's kind of browse full catalog
and you can know about all the
digital knowledge bases about Taiwan.
To begin with you can
use this kind of Taiwan
(speaks Chinese) to start
your research. Yeah.
That's my suggestion.
- Yeah and just in
there's an answer to Q&A,
so everyone can look at that.
(speaks Chinese)
- (speaks Chinese)
Taiwan (speaks Chinese)
(speaks Chinese)
- Okay. (speaks Chinese) James Lynn.
- (speaks Chinese)
Taiwan (speaks Chinese)
(speaks Chinese)
- (speaks Chinese)
(David chuckles)
Taiwan (speaks Chinese)
(speaks Chinese)
- Yeah. If it's digitized,
you'll receive a CD-rom, right? A CD disc
and they'll mail it to you.
- Yes.
- Yeah. At the cost of two
new Taiwan dollars per page,
which is very cheap.
Yeah.
(speaks Chinese)
The last question is
about mainland research.
One user is asking about
early stage building period
land reform in (indistinct)
China between '49 and '56.
I think Shiuon already
part of answered this.
(speaks Chinese) as one of the sources,
but what else? You're muted.
(speaks Chinese)
- (speaks Chinese)
- Okay, so.
Okay. (speaks Chinese)
(speaks Chinese)
(silence)
- (speaks Chinese) (chuckles)
(speaks Chinese)
- (speaks Chinese)
Taiwan (speaks Chinese)
(speaks Chinese)
- So his point is that
there is some overlapping
between the Institute of
Modern History Archives
and to the National
Archives Administration,
so there are some overlap,
so you might get them
from (speaks Chinese).
Okay. There are still some questions,
but we don't have time. We're out of time.
Thank you everybody for joining us
and thank all the panelists.
If you have more questions,
please write to them.
You will receive the email with the link
to the YouTube recording today's talks
and also their PowerPoints
and their email,
so you can write to them.
Emily?
- So on behalf of myself
and Emily,
(David mumbles)
- I want to say a final
thank you to everyone.
You're definitely overtime,
but seeing how little attrition there is
among the attendees,
I think that everyone that is like me,
feeling inspired and motivated,
not just to do this research,
but to come visit Taiwan someday soon.
Thank you to David for moderating.
Everyone, for all the panelists
for being both archivists and historians
and models to us all in
performing this great service
to our field and our students.
I also want to thank the
Council Appreciation Studies at Yale,
especially Stephanie Kim and Richard Sosa,
for providing all of the support
and background for this event.
Thank you to all of the participants
for tuning in this evening.
Please note that our next and
final webinar in this series
will be on Thursday, August
12th, at 8:00 PM eastern,
on the topic of academic jobs
outside the United States.
You will have to
re-register for that webinar
in order to receive the new
link specific to the webinar.
It's not the same link as this webinar.
I'll send that registration
link in the chat.
Thank you all for tuning in.
We'll see you in a couple of weeks
and thank you to everyone
who presented today.
- (speaks Chinese)
(chuckles) (speaks Chines)
Bye bye.